date 39 still estimates of hundreds of
americans thousands of people with green
cards that allows them into our country
thousands of afghan allies completely
abandoned by joe biden behind enemy
lines left to be tortured and murdered
by the taliban terrorists and four u.s
marines they are still in the hospital
tonight nearly a month after the terror
attack at the karzai international
airport in kabul now joe biden he now
claims that he has officially
turned the page on afghanistan taking i
guess a victory lap what an insulting
thing to say he's not lifting a finger
to help our fellow americans that he
abandoned this isn't republican or
democrat they're our fellow americans
come home
and try and get me fired bring them
bring the americans home he hasn't even
mentioned them in 22 days how is that
possible i wonder if the families of
those trapped inside of afghanistan
behind enemy lines i wonder if they've
turned the page i wonder if the families
of the brave soldiers that died last
month in afghanistan i wonder if they've
turned the page when joe could have
easily evacuated everybody and all our
military equipment and our allies and
their families uh before he allowed the
taliban that was on the mar march all
throughout the spring and early summer
he had full control i wonder if the
family of the seven children killed in
biden's botched drone attack i wonder if
they've turned the page but joe biden
thinks that he can simply move on turn
the page and the media mob always gives
them a free pass
just like they did you know on that
fateful drone strike in afghanistan
joe biden killed 10 innocent civilians
including humanitarians and seven
children watch this
president biden is warning that last
night's
drone strike against isis k
that was condemned by the taliban just a
short time ago will likely not be the
last studies of our drone strikes have
suggested that
maybe eight out of ten times we are
hitting the wrong target we have killed
thousands of civilians
unfortunately it would be par for the
course if there was significant
collateral damage from our uh from a
drone strike in afghanistan drone
strikes have been a feature of the
20-year war on terror there are
thousands of u.s drone strikes that have
resulted in thousands of civilian
casualties in several countries and so
you know this has actually been
something that has been fairly
characteristic of the us mission
overseas
what would the media reaction be if it
was donald trump that killed
humanitarians and children in that drone
strike instead of joe biden the mob in
the media they would be hysterical
apoplectic even during president trump's
successful drone strike the one that
took out the world's biggest terrorist
solomoni one of the world's worst evil
terrorists for decades responsible for
the deaths of countless american
soldiers in iraq and elsewhere even
during that successful strike one
without collateral damage oh the media
mob they found a way to be outraged take
a look
trump donald trump gave them exactly
what they wanted by killing suleimani
and then the other element of it now
ever all the bets are off on the nuclear
capacity and ambition by any means if
the americans thought or if trump
thought that by taking out solemnity
iran is going to recalculate recalibrate
its posture or policies in the region i
think what we've seen is the exact
opposite they're going to double down in
the next phase of this it was evident
within the first 24 hours that by taking
out qasim suleimani trump has made the
situation worse and that's dangerous for
our country his decision to strike
somani has the result of endangering u.s
troops and embassies and diplomats
everywhere
no donald trump could have followed the
model of let's say obama and biden and
send cargo planes full of cash and other
currency and try and bribe the mueller's
please be nice to us and then they say
downwards the united states and chant
death to america anyway and burn our
flag less than two years later biden
drones an innocent family kills
humanitarian aid workers seven kids and
america's so-called journalists barely
yawn you don't think the media is
corrupt they are they have no intention
of holding biden accountable they never
have on the campaign trail we witnessed
the media joe was in the media you know
protection program candidate protection
program they allowed him to hide in his
basement for months and not say a word
they never asked them tough questions
and now biden's presidency is an abject
failure his approval numbers they have
plummeted in key battleground states
which according to even fake news cnn
should terrify joe biden look at the
gallup numbers joe's poll numbers have
never been lower and for good reason
inflation is skyrocketing and predicted
to get much worse gas prices up about a
buck 50 gallons since
he took
the presidency became president on
january 20th that's a lot per gallon
we're paying more for everything we buy
more to heat and cool our homes more to
fill our tanks up and after shuttering
pipelines here at home biden is now
begging opec to produce more oil in the
middle east by the way they turned him
down and of course he gave a waiver for
vladimir putin to build his pipeline
does that make sense violent crime is on
the rise in every major city covert is
spreading faster than at any point under
trump biden is rationing crucial
monoclonal antibody treatments seemingly
to hurt red state governors that are
using those
those therapeutics like regeneron to
save lives by the way biden never
mentioned regeneron or monoclonal
antibodies until just a week ago how
pathetic
afghan we know it's a disaster and a
mitigated failure our allies rightly no
longer trust us france they just recall
their ambassador israel they're
threatening to do the same every enemy
around the world is emboldened and
china's threats grow worse by the day
our southern border another unmitigated
disaster you know for seven straight
months joe and his incompetent borders
are kamala harris they twiddle their
thumbs washington post of all places
they went down to texas they asked
migrants why they're making the perilous
trek to the border and even the post
reported quote they decided to risk
everything on a dangerous journey north
after hearing from friends and relatives
and smugglers that the biden
administration is going to let them in
and by the way joe and kamala we didn't
forget you want to know the root cause
of mass migration look in the mirror you
caused it you also invited this mess you
see the images of migrants camped out
under this bridge some 11 000 of them in
texas as we speak they're now being led
into our country by the thousands
without so much as a simple cova test
not even a rapid test no vaccine mandate
shoddy vetting little to no vetting
actually very little paperwork process
release that's the biden
immigration policy in other words coming
to the us on a promise that they will
show up for a future court date almost
none of them ever show up and this week
foxnews.com they actually followed some
of these migrants after they were
processed at the border by biden's team
and then put on a bus in this case
headed to dallas but they're being
dispersed without cova tests all around
the country and no vaccine mandates
either take a look
[Music]
like
[Music]
so
[Music]
free food free transportation no cova
test no vaccine mandate the migrants the
very people that violated our laws did
not respect our sovereignty our borders
they entered this country illegally and
now
with the help of joe biden he's aiding
and abetting they now are dispersed all
over the country this administration is
currently unable and unwilling to say
exactly how many but we do know that
these illegal aliens have not been
vetted like those who immigrate here
legally that's why i support legal
immigration keep in mind some of the
haitian migrants have been incredibly
violent one group actually attacked u.s
pilots and assaulted ice officers on a
transport flight and another group took
over a dhs boss and then fled the scene
before being apprehended and even worse
hhs documents reveal that during one
month a one-month period in february
there were dozens of incidents of sexual
and physical abuse of those
unaccompanied migrant children that joe
put in those cages in the middle of the
pandemic and to his credit texas
governor greg abbott on this program
last night he's now investing 3 billion
state of texas dollars he has now surged
state security forces called up the the
guard in his state to the border even
forming a miles long makeshift border
wall with a fleet of vehicles but that's
how desperate he is because joe biden is
aiding and abetting the whole process
but there's only so much that texas can
do
the biden administration is just
processing and releasing the migrants
into the country they have total
jurisdiction
biden is not only ignoring the laws of
this country he took an oath to uphold
the laws and the constitution of the
united states he's aiding and abetting
the law breaking donald trump had all of
this under complete control and joe
abandoned every single thing that was
working we got to a 25-year low of
illegal immigrants coming into the
country a humanitarian crisis a national
security crisis a public health crisis i
support legal immigration with checks
and vetting to make sure people don't
have radical associations proof that you
have the ability to take care of
yourself and your family financially and
yes in the middle of a pandemic we need
to know that you don't have culvert 19
or any other disease and of course all
of this could be resolved if joe biden
would tell the migrants not to come and
this idiocy of process and release and
go back and finish the wall donald trump
was building and by the way deport
anyone that crosses illegally and by the
way bring back the state of mexico
policy and just simply enforce the law
that's not going to happen biden's
socialist base does not believe in
borders doesn't believe in u.s
sovereignty doesn't even believe in
property rights or the constitution or
the rule of law because there's no
outrage from the left and democrats even
trying to push through their amnesty
using the reconciliation process rather
than actually changing the law and that
3.5 trillion dollar new green deal
socialist monstrosity and tonight
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
she's the real speaker of the house
she's apoplectic over report that
certain asian asian migrants could be
temporarily held at a facility in gitmo
maxine waters is calling biden's
treatment of the haitian migrants worse
than slavery take a look
i'm
pissed i'm unhappy
and i'm not just unhappy with the
cowboys
who were running down haitians
and using their reigns to whip them
i'm happy with the administration
we are following the trump policy he is
the one that does not follow the
constitution and would not allow those
seeking refuge to be able to petition to
get into the country what the hell are
we doing here
what we witness takes us back hundreds
of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery
this is biden's policies by the way
trump's been out of office a solid nine
months by the way make no mistake an
all-out civil war is about to break out
in the democratic party right now maxine
waters aoc the radical squad they hold
all of the cards nancy pelosi knows it
she's speaker in the house in name only
she's terrified of all of them now this
is why the iron dome funding that was
left out of the democrats new budget
that's why democrats are trying hard to
pass this insane five trillion dollar
new
uh green new deal socialist legislation
human infrastructure they call it this
is why the crisis at the southern border
has imploded hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else